Ngày Hà miệng bài tháng 1, I Saran dự kiến phát triển đồng hồ đặt tại còn trường con tín ở theo viết
như thưởng đến từ giang kể từ cuộc tấn công mềm bài tháng 1, năm 2018
Đồng thái giản ra sau khi côn đổi nước ngày đã thu hồi vào anh thái giận giang tí thế còn tín I Saran của công thái giải gà ra
khi lại lộ lực tám trăm bốn nước bốn ngày tín kiến và đưa các con tín còn sống lẫn thiệt bản trở về nước
theo côn đổi Saran, 2 có công tín của công được xác định la RUN LEEDLY
một xí quan cạnh xác thiệt mạnh trong cuộc tấn công của người làm hành in tu trọng hay bà
vừa tu hồi thế của ngoàn tất một trong những vụ trong tâm của giải đoạn một trong thật yên bản dò Mỹ làm trung dàn
bốn đặt yêu kênh năng đầu cho việc chào chào tọn bộ con tín
tại Saran, thức khách ngày được coi là giấu mốt mạnh ý nghĩa hàng gắn sau nhiều tháng các gia đình nạn nhân liên tục tập hợp tài vị trí
chức đồng hồ tại khoảng trường con tín để các gọi đưa thân nhân chờ về nhà
các hoa đồng tường miệng và lẽ thăm đồng hồ dự kiến sẽ có sự tháng dự của nhiều gia đình
quan trước và cạnh những người tự bị giám dữ
tuy nhiên, việc khác lại在 đoạn chào chào con tín của mở ra những trình cạnh mới về từng lại
giải gà ra trong khi Saran và Mỹ tục đẩy lộ trình chuyển sang ra đoạn tiếp theo của thật
bao gồm còn li mới và giải giá bước lượng ha mắt
không chào hồi giá này tìm cách truy trì và cho của bộ máy sinh sự và lực lượng an đi nhận có
những khách biệt sâu sắc đó cho thấy con đường hộ mình bắn tại gà ra vẫn đối mặt với nhiều thách thức